[Música]
luís três semanas
a direção é que a pouco você vai me
chamar de doutora
tem gente que acha que é chique que é
bonito nem sabe que esses tratamentos
foram dispensados desde 1991
olha esse documento aqui
cumprimentando-o cordialmente solícitos
bons préstimos de vossa senhoria no
sentido de esclarecer pontos referentes
ao processo epigrafado certo de contar
com a sua colaboração antecipa os meus
agradecimentos e aproveito o ensejo para
renovar protestos de elevada estima e
distinta consideração a receita gente
vai olhar fala tá bonito tá chique
quantos termos difíceis cultos essa
pessoa escreve bem
não entendi nada mais tabu e preto
naquele início cumprimentando-o
cordialmente o documento oficial não foi
feito para cumprimentar ninguém
solicito os bons préstimos de vossa
senhoria parece assim que eu tenho
daquele jeitinho tem que puxar o saco de
alguém para conseguir alguma coisa no
sentido de esclarecer pontos referentes
ao processo epigrafado pontos referentes
ao processo que pontos ou esses processo
inpe gravado sabe o que significa
processo epigrafado é porque antigamente
aquele trecho ele assunto se chamava
epígrafe hoje em dia se chama assunto
mas as pessoas curvos continuam usando
epigrafado parece que fica mais bonito e
continuando certos de contar com a sua
colaboração o secretário nem disse se
vai colaborar mas eu já estou certo de
contar com a colaboração de um jeitinho
de um empurrãozinho
se essa intenção use o futuro espero
contar com a sua colaboração ficaremos
grátis com a sua colaboração aproveito o
ensejo para renovar propensos elevada
estima e distinta consideração nossa mas
ficou chique se vocês sabem que em 1937
nós tínhamos 15 fechou os oficiais
hoje são somente dois atenciosamente
respeitosamente mas tem gente que
continuo usando acho que fica bonito
chega ser falso às vezes eu nem conheço
a pessoa nem sei quem é nem têm elevada
estima e consideração coisa nenhuma
esse aqui quem já viu como é que poderia
ser uma linha solicita esclarecer a data
de início do serviço de consultoria
contratada por meio do processo número
total e ainda mais objetivo mais preciso
eu digo que eu quero quem já viu
documento que termina assim colocamos
inteiramente ao seu dispor para iguais
quer esclarecimentos que se fizerem
necessários
colocamos inteiramente ao seu dispor
é falso e mentiroso ninguém saiu inteiro
dispor de ninguém
então vamos lá em casa lavar passar
cozinhar para quaisquer esclarecimentos
a é tão me disse você ganha quanto
casado solteiro quaisquer
esclarecimentos eu posso perguntar o que
eu quiser
mas a pessoa complemento diz que se
fizerem necessários
alguém vai pedir um esclarecimento que
não seja necessário mas eu quero ser
gentil colocamos à disposição para mais
esclarecimentos referentes ao processo é
um assunto muito mais objetivo
só que eu tenho certeza de que tem gente
que não pensar nessas trás desses textos
lembrou-se
dos tempos em que nós escreveu zhou
touch logra fomos datilografar vamos
nessa máquina linda de datilografia
porque esses trechos são antigos de uma
redação antiga de uma cultura que mudou
e eu tenho certeza de que se você for
propor mudanças um superior hierárquico
pode ser que ele diga sim mas por que
você quer mudar
aqui sempre foi assim parece aquele
control c control v copiar/colar salvar
como porque esses documentos continuam
assim se já mudaram há tanto tempo
certamente porque a gente não aprende na
escola fazer um ofício memorando
relatório parecer vai para a faculdade
vai fazer o artigo uma resenha resumo
vai para a administração pública tem que
fazer um ofício memorando uma nota
técnica onde é que a gente aprendeu a
fazer esses documentos
aí aparece uma alma generosa em laos e
disto é que esse modelo mas esse modelo
com referência e como surgiu para você
como alguns aquele modelo vai ficando e
vai ficando às vezes você até no início
tinha consciência de que aqueles
elementos estariam adequados mas que
você também foi usando usando sem se dar
conta de que são elementos antigos e até
antiquados pru uma administração pública
mais moderna
hoje quando nós falamos em conceito de
competência comunicativa que é o que eu
quero compartilhar com vocês hoje é que
competência reúnem três conceitos
básicos
eu tenho que ter conhecimento sobre o
assunto que eu quero transmitir sobre as
informações
eu tenho também ter conhecimento sobre o
formato daquele documento qual é o
vocativo adequado o endereçamento com a
padronização eu tenho que ter também a
habilidade que é o saber fazer saber
mesmo
dirigir da maneira adequada mas não
basta só isso mais importante é mesmo a
atitude a atitude de querer fazer bem
feito
quando então alguém perguntar pra você
que mudar se aqui sempre foi assim
responda por que eu quero fazer a
diferença para nós termos uma
instituição melhor aquelas práticas
antigas demonstram revela uma cultura de
uma instituição antiga
se eu quero uma instituição moderna
renovada pensando em quem vai ler aquele
documento eu tenho que mudar as minhas
táticas
muito obrigada é paula olha só é é
extremamente vossa senhoria poderia se
aproximar é porque eu tenho uma pequena
dúvida se as pessoas não mudaram o jeito
de escrever até agora você acha que tem
chances disso acontecer hoje a partir
daqui 16 acho que nós podemos fazer a
mudança
acredito que podemos fazer a mudança
entanto é rapidinho todo o mundo 2 a 2
um de frente para o outro em que adriano
me ajuda rápida de rapidinho rapidamente
você vai olhar para esse colega e vai
ver como ele está e roupas acessórios
cabelo de negócios carro rapidamente de
costas de gostas cada atenção cada um
vai fazer em si três mudanças rapidinho
a roupa cabelo acessório que você quiser
mudar pode uma mudança grande uma
mudança pequena vou contar até três do 3
você vai ficar de frente para o seu
parceiro e vai identificar melhor as
mudanças que ele fez o 2 3 mas eu toda
amassada também
eu fui além do avc abril aqui botão
abril em campo você abrir aqui você
dizer botou você votou o cabelo atrás da
original
háháhá foi difícil
oi pode sentar quem tem melhor pode usar
se o colega não conseguiu
pode contar pra ele eu quero saber quem
percebeu as três mudanças levando a mão
bem alto que eu quero ver as três
mudanças
eu não percebi só duas só dois é preciso
uma quem não percebeu nada
essa é boa foi mais fácil perceber as
grandes mudanças as pequenas mudanças
certamente eu viro e a pessoa tá com a
roupa toda amassada na minha frente a
quase na cara tá vendo a peça perdão
pela minha mas eu quero saber quem é que
o colega fez uma mudança pequena e você
percebeu um botãozinho e você percebeu
todas as mudanças são importantes as
grandes mudanças se as pequenas mudanças
não têm uma talvez uma mais importante
que o outro mas todas as mudanças fazem
a diferença
vocês acham que vocês podem fazer a
mudança podem então olha só vou precisar
de concentração de vocês nós vamos fazer
como se fosse aquela ola de estádio
sabe quem tiver alguma coisa aí tira
tira do colo que a gente vai precisar de
concentração e da participação de todos
porque na verdade pra fazer a mudança de
todos
então vamos começar assim ó vou fazer um
teste com a ola bem rapidinho então tem
que se concentrar 125 começa aí os dois
erros
o legal foi bonito foi bonito foi bonito
só que isso não é fazer a mudança
isso não é fazer chover já acreditam que
vocês podem fazer chover você fazia a
ola isso é fazer só um mecanismo aí a
torcida do flamengo do corinthians
consegue foi então que até a do flamengo
então vamos lá olha só agora é sério o
mecanismo é esse mas pra fazer a mudança
a gente tem que fazer chover no que nos
couber certo e aqui vamos fazer chover
aqui dentro deixe dessa sala e vai
começar assim
aí com a ola silêncio concentração
todo mundo tem que fazer a sua parte
forte continua um são barulho do vento
os primeiros pingos da chuva chegando
forte
usa chuva eo vento levou chuva
[Aplausos]
o que ouvi o barulho da chuva
eu também vocês fizeram chover aqui
dentro o que vocês farão pelo mundo
então vamos assumir esse compromisso de
fazer a nossa parte por um maior num
país melhor por uma administração melhor
pro mundo melhor
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]